[Music]
now in other marriage news Scarlett
Johansson has been making headlines as
she goes through her second divorce but
let me tell you this Scarlett is as
tough as the characters that she plays
and that is saying a lot well you see
her latest movie goes to the shelf
I'm going in the half human half cyborg
major is just the latest kick butt role
for Scarlett the psychokinetic Lucy and
a superhero Black Widow also come to
mind and playing these characters that
have been on a quest for self-identity
wondering like you and your own
experience your own life your own
journey if you could relate to that the
major is curious about herself I've been
also on that journey of self-discovery
that's all part of the forward momentum
part of that forward momentum maybe
dating again as she told Howard Stern
this morning how are you gonna date are
you on guard as a woman who is famous
you're wealthy I'm on guard because I
have a young daughter and that young
daughter two and a half year old Rose
may not see ghosts in the show anytime
soon
how will they think your daughter has to
be before she actually gets to watch it
oh gosh well you know you're asking the
wrong person because my mom I think
shows showed me like Silence of the
Lambs Broadway nine well I don't know
what she was thinking so I don't know
I'd say at least like probably like 11
or 12 I appreciate the pg-13 mists of
this movie I think that's fair now I'll
say this I bet when she does see it
she's gonna love it as much as I did I'm
telling you right now one of the best
movies I've seen
[Music]